vor kelly ist schon lange im truthahn
business und davon überzeugt dass keiner
so gute bio vögel liefert für den
traditionellen weihnachtsbraten der
briten wie er in der branche kamen
bisher fast alle arbeiter aus osteuropa
viele von ihnen sind in der pandemie
nach hause gefahren und konnten dann
wegen des drecks it nur mit arbeitsvisum
zurück für kelly und seine kollegen ist
das ein riesenproblem
ihnen allen fehlen arbeitskräfte
vorausschauend haben die truthahn
züchter 15 prozent weniger eier
ausbrüten lassen
nun gibt es natürlich nicht genug
britische truthähne auf unseren höfen
manche mussten sogar schließen die
supermärkte brauchen die pute aber nur
können wir sie nicht liefern also kaufen
die britischen supermärkte jetzt bei
europäischen produzenten ein völlig
absurd
polnische truthähne britisches christmas
eine ironie des dragset
britanniens schweinefarmen leiden
ebenfalls wenn auch anders hier warten
120.000 tiere und vor allem ihre züchter
auf schlachter und metzger die nicht
mehr da sind
unsere situation ist düster wir sind nur
wochen entfernt von einer massen dann
müssten die tiere auf den höfen getötet
und verbrannt werden ein armutszeugnis
kate moore und die schweinebauern
protestieren vor dem parteitag der
konservativen in manchester drinnen
lautet das motto wieder aufbauen aber
besser nicht nur bei den landwirten
stellt sich der eindruck ein die
regierung wisse nicht so genau wie
stück für stück scheint genau das chaos
einzutreten vor dem die praxis gegner
immer gewarnt haben schlangen an den
tankstellen leere regale die
energiepreise steigen und die steuern so
auch die inflation im schnitt 2000 euro
teurer wird das leben dieses jahr für
eine familie gleichzeitig kürzt die
regierung die sozialhilfe für die
ärmsten im land
die bilder ähneln zunehmend denen vom
winter der unzufriedenheit
1979 als die energiepreise stiegen und
streiks das land lahmlegten es war der
anfang vom ende der damaligen labour
regierung auch nun droht großbritannien
ein sehr bitterer winter der premier
aber tut bei der abschlussrede seines
parteitags als liefe alles genau nach
plan
das ist die richtung in die sich dieses
land jetzt entwickeln hohe löhne gute
ausbildung hohe produktivität und
dadurch niedrige steuern das wird dauern
und manchmal wird das schwierig sein
aber es ist der wandel für den die
menschen 2016 gestimmter wollte tvo in
36 team
auch kate moore hatte für den eu
austritt gestimmt
darum ging es nicht beim drechseln beim
rexit ging es darum hat erotischer zu
sein dass wir uns um uns selbst kümmern
und besser kontrollieren können welche
lebensmittel ins land gehen nichts davon
ist passiert
viele unternehmer fordern dass die
regierung ihren kurs korrigiert und
schnell viele arbeitsvisa erteilt doch
johnson verteidigt was vom brh exit
übrig ist das ende der freizügigkeit
großbritannien dürfe nicht länger auf
billige ausländische arbeitskraft setzen
tatsächlich steigen nun vor allem die
löhne von lastwagenfahrern um bis zu 30
prozent manche unternehmen locken mit
5000 pfund einstiegs bonus doch noch
immer fehlen zigtausende fahrer das
militär muss bei den benzinlieferungen
aushelfen und die regierung schreibt an
alle deutschen im land die einen alten
führerschein haben und deshalb
siebeneinhalb tonnen fahren dürfen sie
sollten sich für britannien ans steuer
setzen kopfschütteln vor der deutschen
samstags schule die nord london wenn mir
nicht vorstellen dass viele leute den
folgen werden die meisten deutschen die
in großbritannien sind haben sicherlich
ein job und den aufzugeben um lkw fahrer
zu werden finde ich eine sehr naive
annahme ja also ich würde mich totlachen
was soll ich denn jetzt noch
lastwagenfahrerin werden also ich finde
damit macht man sich auch regierung eher
lächerlich wenn man so
unüberlegt die briefe verschickt ähnlich
erfolglos der versuch ganz schnell 300
tank lastwagen fahrer im ausland
anzuheuern gemeldet haben sich bisher 27
im eiltempo werden nun britische fahrer
angelernt adrien anderson macht den job
seit 30 jahren und sorgt jetzt für
nachwuchs im akkord jeder den ich gerade
ausbilder hat schon jetzt einen job für
die woche drauf die firmen
heute mit ein zwei tagen erfahrungen
alles egal die schicken dich mit einem
26 tonner mit nach london anstatt die
erst mal auf der landstraße anfangen zu
haben
auch beschleunigt die regierung das
prüfungsverfahren bisher musste man erst
einen siebeneinhalb tonner gefahren
haben bevor man an den 26 tonner
gelassen wurde die zwischenstation fällt
nun weg adrian hält auch das für
gefährlich
ist die neuen fahrer tatsächlich
unterwegs sind kann man nicht wissen ob
das eine gute idee war oder eine sehr
schlecht
grund genug sich den kummer ums land
herunter zu spülen aber auch die freude
ist getrübt in londons ausgeh viertel
soho haben viele läden ihre
öffnungszeiten reduziert oder ganz
geschlossen alle suchen personal früher
kamen köche und kellner aus ganz europa
jetzt sind nur noch die da die die
auflagen für eine aufenthaltsgenehmigung
erfüllen beata aus polen etwa
meine mitarbeiter haben jetzt lange tage
normalerweise arbeiten sie so 42
höchstens 45 stunden aber jetzt müssen
sie 50 stunden ran oder auch mal 52
ich habe momentan wenig hoffnung dass
irgendwas besser wird
aber es muss denn so kann die britische
wirtschaft sich nicht entwickeln
das natürlich würde der premier als
schwarzmalerei abtun johnson mag keinen
plan haben aber er hat eine vision und
die sieht sich und das land auf dem weg
in eine strahlende zukunft
[Musik]